let me show you one of my favorite soups
to make using all the cheap cuts from a
salmon so I'm using salmon heads and
Bone scraps that I bought for just a few
dollars each give it a rinse and then
add chicken broth for more flavor I
usually use homemade broth but since I
didn't have the time I'm using boxed
skin my foam as it rises to the top and
then for my aromatics I'm using
lemongrass galingo and lime leaves
simmer this for at least 30 minutes and
then strain the broth and this part is
time consuming but pick off the meat
from the bones and there's a lot of
really tender parts in the head and
color too season with salt and fish
sauce and then to put this together add
rice chili oil cilantro Thai Pepper and
a squeeze of lime